what up what up it's OT the real you can
catch me on the bootleg Kev show
bootleg Kev podcast we have a special
guest in here my guy's album just
dropped he just did that BT Cipher y'all
saw it man
my friend a lot of people think that we
we could be cousins
but we are indeed not related not that I
know of
OT the real what up what up welcome sir
welcome what's good man first of all man
um things been moving congratulations on
the BT look yeah man big uh big moves
real real great for Bill to be part of
that how did that whole thing come about
like uh I know you said Snoop reposting
your [ __ ] kind of helped with that right
yeah you know we believe so you know
what I'm saying but you know for the
most part we just been consistently
dropping videos and um they've been
getting placed on BT shout out Breeze
um connecting the bridges on that making
everything connect and uh yeah you know
they hit us up this year and said come
on anyway and here we are today uh so
for people who don't know man give me a
little bit of your background because I
think a lot of people know you as like a
Philly rapper even though you're not
necessarily from Philly yeah yeah yeah
definitely I'm from Mass if you watch
some of my other interviews and [ __ ] oh
it goes real into like you know I left
Mass you know
part of my criminal life that I had when
I was younger and I ended up in Philly
and that's when you know I went to
prison for a while when I came home
that's when you know I started to push
the music and uh yeah here we are uh how
long were you in prison like like five
and a half that's a serious bid man
some would say uh being like you being a
car so obviously there's like politics
are different in all prisons everywhere
uh California
I believe all right it's definitely
different out here yeah I think like the
peckerwoods and the Southsiders are
together and then uh I think blacks and
the others and what is like when you
were locked up because you obviously are
a hip-hop artist you got flavor like do
the whites stay with the whites in
prison where you were at like how was
like your prison experience man
I remember when I was my the first
prison I was in was boss I've been in
like six joints the first joint I was in
was was Massachusetts was Worcester
house he was just saying
um and in what's the house I remember uh
I remember I was I was 17 getting tried
as an adult so I really didn't have no
business being in there they just they
figured they'd keep me for the last two
months till I turned 18 so they put me I
was in population but I was so young and
so scrawny that nobody bothered me at
all they like I looked like you're a kid
they were like what the [ __ ] are you
doing here I remember showing my papers
to people and being like no look I'm 17
and people would be like yo what the
[ __ ] like yo you need anything here man
so they were like looking out for you it
was like that's how it was in what's the
house where I landed at that time it
wasn't you know whoever had it under
control it was under control it was all
right but I remember two uh two Irish
kids came to myself older guys and they
were like hey bud you got your paperwork
and I was like what the [ __ ] is that you
know I mean they're like all the
paperwork from you getting arrested and
[ __ ] so I was like yeah
he said look you know if you um you know
if you got any problems or anything you
come see us you know I'm saying if like
a black dude or Puerto Rican dude or you
go at it with one of them you don't go
at it with them you just come see us and
we'll go and I wasn't having problems
with no one so I was like all right I
was like looking at him like the [ __ ]
man yeah they're like yeah you're good
look at my paperwork and left so I seen
like that there was some type of order
but you know I didn't really
you know I had so much other [ __ ] going
on I couldn't really focus on it but
like and then I remember like hitting
the Delaware prison like the joints I
was in Delaware like you weren't allowed
to sleep
I'm saying like you couldn't sleep I
seen I see some crazy [ __ ] down there in
Delaware it's nasty down there you could
you could do your time in the prison or
if you're short time you can choose to
go across the parking lot to uh the vop
center you know which is a punishment
Camp so like through being there like
boot camp yo my man they wake you up 4
a.m 5 a.m just reading last names put
your boots on put your boots on so that
would like Excel your sentence so you
get out soon yeah it would like it would
be like if you do a program in the in
the vop center you know it might be like
six months less than your two years I'm
so it was worth it but you weren't
allowed to sleep did you do that you did
the vop
yeah but I had to do vop because um
you know I left Massachusetts on the run
and I went to Delaware and I remember I
like served on the cover cop and
Massachusetts wouldn't come get me so
Delaware put me on probation and
probation gets me and they're like
they're like all right you're 19. you
never finished high school go back to
high school
um so he put me into High School up the
street from the house that I was
trapping out of I had my own house so I
was going to school during the day to
appease probation so we were on
probation trapping out of your own crib
at 19. yeah and then at night Friday
nights I had to report to the vop center
and go to prison from Friday to Sunday
and I get out Sunday night and go back
to school Monday morning so every every
weekend they put me on a different pod
because they wouldn't want me to go back
to the same pod and bring it back you
know something and bring a bomb in right
so like people would be dying trying to
get me to bring a bomb and like
everybody be trying yo you're a
Weekender because they had to stay they
were all doing for people who don't know
what a bomb a bomb is that's like a
balloon yeah whatever yeah you know that
would be something you put up yours no I
don't know about that you know I mean
I'm just I'm scared
[Music]
you know what I'm saying I almost got
hemmed up in a situation down there one
time because of that because you had
some money me and a bunch of weekenders
were all in the cell and they put us on
the cell together
they had us all stripping like everybody
take your shirts off and I remember I
like I don't know what happened but I
heard something hit the ground like that
it wasn't you it might have been okay
but I looked down and then and there was
a bag and [ __ ] and I was like and I'm
looking and like no one sees it well
everyone's still getting undressed and
[ __ ] so I kind of step on it and do the
swipe wow notices it and then when
they're cleaning it out they're like yo
hold on what is that and all the other
weekend to start ratting on me right
away they're like this [ __ ] young
prick because they're all you know
they're all yeah you know they had it
with me I'm going in this small like
straight gas taking another living the
life yeah like look at this [ __ ] high
school I'm like a 19 year old junior in
high school Jesus it's like Billy
Madison yeah with the Trapper it was
something crazy so like we kept getting
I kept getting raided and you know there
was nothing to do down there you know
what I'm saying so I was I was hunted
down there in Delaware you know I feel
like sneaking a balloon of drugs inside
of your orifices of any capacity is just
dangerous because what if we bust open
like do you ever know somebody but not
even that you're going in there with
yourself sneakers though like I mean I'm
not even talking about you I just mean
like you always hear like like chicks
will go visit dudes and like sneak [ __ ]
inside of them like you know I'm like I
wonder if that ever goes left like if
the balloon pops open inside of a chick
and then she [ __ ] overdoses she died
yeah people die all the time you heard
of that I got a homie who's tried to
stuff a half a half ounce of crack in
his ass and he died in the police
station it's a serious serious amount of
crap to try to finish your butt
I'm just saying the amount of lube
needed for that to transpire that's two
percent gay for sure it probably doesn't
matter how many layers of bag are in
between that you know because it's it's
your body's acidic you got acids in you
yeah it should be like you should at
least it's like when you uh put it in a
corner and like wrap it into another
corner right it's like if you vacuum
seal a pack and put it in the mail you
should at least do it three times
allegedly I mean you know once you start
once that machine gets the buzzing you
know you might just do it you just got
to make sure you get you're good with
the Poke test you know I don't I
wouldn't know anything about that but
I've heard I don't know yeah yeah uh so
look so you're 19 years old so just so
we can
rewind this because this is pretty crazy
so you get locked up at 17 you get out
well I turned 18 in jail and I got on
the ankle brace and I cut it off so I
slid so I've been on the run forever
like so you were on the run pretty much
my whole life until I've just maxed out
my prison sentence just now like two
years ago I basically you know it's been
like a nice interest rate and a half so
you cut off your ankle bracelet at 18
you end up getting back into the system
to the point where they make you go back
to high school yeah like they they were
like yo Massachusetts won't extradite
you they're not they won't pay to get
you extradited so we're not gonna hold
you on that case up this is in Delaware
yeah so Delaware is like we're just
gonna charge you with your cases here
and we're just gonna make sure you go
back to school and then and I got raided
down there again and I bailed out before
probation could put the detainer on me
and I ran I left Delaware so now I'm 20
and I'm in Philly I'm saying so for a
certain I just you're a 19 year old
junior in high school
Monday through Friday
it's my birthday man it's your birthday
happy birthday think about it how many
years ago were you in prison celebrating
this day yeah
some ashtrays and some lighters yeah of
course
um I will smoke with you my man yeah
yeah please do I this thing might have
clipped up my apocal I might need to
roll another one but uh if not I got a
box of drugs right there on top of the
uh Mortal Kombat
um so so yeah you know wait wait wait so
look you're 19.
a 19 year old junior in high school with
his own house like 10 years from the
school okay so you have your own house
right next to the school that they're
forcing you to go to so their officer
the Dare officers like stops me one day
and he's like yo he's like I know what
goes on at that house down the street
he's like don't bring that [ __ ] in this
school and I'm just like all right right
I'm gonna argue with you I was a young
kid so your your daily schedule though
was going to school
at night you're doing your thing you're
getting your money and then on the
weekends you're going to this Camp I'm
going to jail I'm going to prison oh
you're going to jail in Louisiana and
that's not the vop thing no the vop is
is the prison so you're going to put
your you're doing the vop program on the
weekend yeah yeah yeah I'm getting out
Sunday night
so I had like one weekend one weekend
left that was my second to last weekend
and that [ __ ] hit the floor and them
cats are like oh
that's it as he comes in here is that
when you jetted so so no no so I'm I'm
in the [ __ ] prison [ __ ] boss naked
[ __ ] getting accused the drugs on the
floor they're saying is mine fell out of
another guy I'm like that ain't [ __ ]
mine like who's this I don't [ __ ]
know but they can't prove it at that
point so then they're like look and they
Point there's a [ __ ] camera oh so I'm
like damn so now I'm like it ain't mine
double down you know what I'm saying
[ __ ] you it ain't mine still I don't
care what the camera says I'm double
down yeah and uh you know I was young so
Sunday night came and they read all the
weekend his names to leave and they
didn't read mine
so I'm like yo
see you on
I got school tomorrow
the [ __ ] back to your rap man the [ __ ]
are you talking about man they say you
ain't you ain't going home you're like
you're the one who brought the dope in
everything's dope to them yeah Delaware
is the South it's the beginning of the
South okay I'm saying once you hit
Delaware you're in the South it's
different than being in Pennsylvania
it's a whole different culture I'm
telling you man like even the music
[ __ ] was listening to like Mike
Jones and [ __ ] down there
not nothing against them no nothing
against Mike Jones I could use a couple
singles too but I'm saying like you know
like it's a different vibe down there
and um
and now hold on
happy birthday
hey this is this guy was birthday right
here man yes but it's a hell of a
birthday man who let calf said fly up
but uh where was I
[ __ ] it you said that uh they said
you're staying oh yes because you were
supposed to they say you're staying
so the next morning comes and they bring
me out
in front of a video Court judge
and I'm just like y'all got a double
they're like listen six month program
starting today
or you could go catch this three-piece
for bringing drugs in the jail
I'm like nope not nope [ __ ] that not
mine nope not mine they're like we got
you on camera I'm like I want to see the
camera they said we don't got to show it
to you so we show it to the judge you'll
see it at the same time
so I was like damn so I remember calling
home telling my mom and she's like oh
you got to take the deal but I know
they're listening and Delaware is nasty
so I'm like no I'm not taking the deal
Mom I'm innocent and I'm saying because
I know that this is all part of it and
you probably can't get in trouble for
kicking it like kicking it under the bed
or whatever you know what I'm saying
plausible deniability
has gotten me out of some James I'm
saying so you know they got approved I'm
saying nothing right [ __ ] ain't mine you
know I'm saying so they put me in front
of the judge and the judge is like on
the screen he asked the CEO because the
CEO is like acting like the [ __ ]
prosecutor this [ __ ] is like [ __ ]
small town [ __ ] going on down here guys
over my shoulder like your honor we
don't actually have those cameras
recording
they're just there for monetary the
judge is like yo let him go right now
and get him back I want him back in
school by this afternoon let me back out
that's amazing then I went on a run
so you you were on the run for uh how
many years would you say that you were
just kind of ducking the law before it
caught up to you
from like 2002
to
2000 until I went to prison in 2010 2011
and then and you say you were in for
five and a half from five and a half
there yeah so so it was on the run and
then I got out and was on Parole so I
was I didn't max that out for another
four years after that so it was almost a
20-year run wow
well for people who don't understand too
is like when you're on uh parole like
that it's almost like
as close to being in prison as I mean I
don't know how your parole was I guess
everyone's Philly sweet like I suggest
anybody
who's on parole in like Jersey or
something like that everybody's killing
everybody in Philly right so like if you
don't get caught shooting a gun at
somebody
you're not going to jail like I would
suggest you relocate to Philadelphia
if you put your parole in Philly they
don't got time to come see you oh that's
it they don't got time I'm saying yo so
what what was it that ended up happening
where everything actually ended up
catching up to you because I've had some
friends that were on similar
I got a book in Philly after you know I
landed in Philly like 06.
07 I found like Fishtown Kensington
built my little team up had a little run
until like 2010.
got booked
got caught sawing someone else's [ __ ]
someone else's [ __ ] I got pulled in
got grabbed and uh people with Talent
um
they offered me a four to eight I tapped
real quick because you know I was over
100 grams over 100 grams for a convicted
felon at the time was a mandatory seven
and a half to 15 but the seven and a
half and 15 can be a back number it
doesn't got to be your front number so
you could get a four to eight and that
falls in that seven and a half to
Fifteen so I took the sweetest deal that
they offered right away damn when I went
Upstate Delaware I put a detainer on me
I said what do you guys want they said
two and a half years plus the felony
conviction I'm like well you're running
right now they said yes
well they they put a detainer on me
right away and I I got in the listen I
got in the dog program in in the jail I
was at and did you have a pet yeah me
and me and one one other dude were in a
building where a bunch of dudes had like
rooms like this size but there was a
crate for a dog and you got these [ __ ]
up dogs and like you'd groom them and
like walk them and if they'd get adopted
after so it made you look good from when
you saw the board and you were doing
good you know I was like and you had a
little friend and you had a [ __ ] dog
and you could go outside on the compound
at any time and walk to any block
because your dog had to piss and you
were just walking around so there's a
lot of sweet deal yeah it was a good job
people would hate on that show you in
the dog program I'm like [ __ ] out of
here [ __ ] you would take the dog too
yeah how many dogs did you have
wow actually I didn't do good in the dog
program really but what you know my dog
died that's weird
My Dog Died nah you know that's where
like work at the game
that came to where it was like I had
like weight room and football games
coming up and playing all these Sports
you're playing football in prison
volleyball man
so you're walking dogs
that's not going well because you know
it wasn't that you gotta you got a sign
out sheet on the wall of every time you
take the dog out to walk him and this
broader was running the program was like
you know you're not bringing the dog out
enough you're not [ __ ] and you're not
taking them off for long enough periods
of time and after a while I was like
listen you [ __ ] [ __ ] I said I'm
trying to make [ __ ] parole here and
go home and [ __ ] live my life I love
the dogs but like the dog don't gotta go
out nine times a day the [ __ ] dog's
getting adopted and sitting in a cage
while the people go to work I'm [ __ ]
running back you got me right now
listen [ __ ] I got a game I got a game
tomorrow
so you know
yeah you know how did they divvy up this
is what happened okay go ahead
so
so they let you take a picture with the
dog
[ __ ] up yeah hey let me think let me
put this down they let me take a picture
with the dog right
so I got a court date coming up in
Massachusetts right
so I send the picture of the dog to my
mom
my mom goes on my behalf to
Massachusetts right we're just trying to
get up we're trying to plead guilty so
they start running the time yeah while
the map because the people four and a
half years going the other time's gonna
get eaten up so they're like oh um
the dude who was the head of probation
at the time was [ __ ] working with
adopting dogs at the Patriots games he
was putting the dog adopt the dogs up on
the screen at the Patriots game so my
mother holds the picture off of me
[ __ ] the dog in court I guess they
you know talk and they're like yeah
we'll give him you know I think it was
another two years okay dog saved just in
time
another felony conviction yeah she was
just adding up against me but I was
getting out of [ __ ] though so I was you
know shout out to the shout out to the
dog I think his name was Boozer Boozer
like Carlos yeah
bro
back to the football how do you divvy up
a football team and because football is
a draft it's a draft he's going to draft
so you gotta sign up okay a bunch of
people sign up to be coaches every coach
gets to freeze one player so you got
people going all over the jail trying to
like buy a player to freeze with them
Jesus and then they go in and they have
their draft and [ __ ] they have a draft
what round were you drafted in you know
I was a whole player man [ __ ] you
talking so would you play like what was
your position in prison
pause
I'm talking about on the football field
on the football field were you running
back were you a tight end pause
quarterback cornerback no well I'd say
I'd say uh probably a tight end me pause
it yeah actually you'd want to be hey
out of all position she would want to be
at tight end in prison
I'm saying you'd want to be Sports a big
though in prison man sports are what
gets you through [ __ ] yeah you get to
play you gotta be basketball I mean
obviously uh I think out here they got
like there's like a big baseball league
in the prisons in Cali yeah yeah like
back in the day they used to play like
the guards I played you know baseball
and I was it's men's softball in there
and [ __ ] the ball got to hit the plate
to be a strike any like crazy riots
while you were locked up
in in the well so in the county in
Philly yeah there was a lot there's
probably that's the that was probably
like that in County huh and then yeah
absolutely I mean the county in Philly
eats up everything I saw you know and
that's what they say about LA County
Jail they say it's like [ __ ] hell on
Earth like for even if you're only there
for like two weeks it's like the worst I
was with a kid who got I was with a kid
who had a DUI in Philly and he was on
probation for it and he got a DUI out in
LA and Philly went and got him and made
him ride the bus back and every so every
so they ride the bus for a couple hours
and they drop you off at the nearest
prison and you sleep there then the next
morning he was on a prison tour you go
on a prison tour yeah you go on a joint
that's why it's terrible you got to look
at the states you're [ __ ] with
because some states will go anywhere you
see how Massachusetts wouldn't even come
to Delaware to get me
the mother you know so Massachusetts
won't extradite unless it's like
something crazy if it's like not worth
their time yeah for me it was like
you know Coke and
grand larceny and [ __ ]
what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our new
sponsors our family at hardean Las Vegas
you see what it is you see what it is
welcome to the family heart Dean man
we're so excited I've been going to
Hardy for so many years for people who
don't know Hardin is that premium
cannabis dispensary the number one
award-winning dispensary in Las Vegas
I'm talking the biggest and best
selection of cannabis product and of
course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're the [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to hardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on the
bootleg head podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to
hardinlasvegas.com that's j-a-r-d-i in
Las vegas.com and don't forget when you
go to Vegas you go to Jardin tell them I
sent you and they're only might throw a
little extra little eighth in the bag or
something they're a little discount the
bootleg discount you know what I'm
saying get them packwoods too they give
me a Packwood the other day that geez
I'm still recovering from that [ __ ] blew
my whole [ __ ] face off in the best
way Hardy in Las Vegas all right shout
out to them let's get back to the
interview
yeah that's what that's what them first
it's crazy because like with your
background obviously you know it
the the
it turned me into a nice guy well I was
gonna say like for you to get out when
you got out
and then start from zero when it comes
to having like a they're doing this rap
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying like
it says a lot about like I guess just
like your determination man because like
I'm assuming you're writing hella raps
in jail and [ __ ] yeah like that's when I
when I started doing that time when I
was fighting that case when when
Pennsylvania had me
Delaware put a detainer on me right
there's no more bail don't even think
about that [ __ ] you're just waiting for
court dates now now you're just you're
in jail you just yeah now you know where
you're gonna be at now you're trying to
run a poker table you're trying to get
you know I mean you're trying to start
living off the land yeah your mind ain't
out there no more it's inside but once
your mind's inside
you're all right you can do it you just
gotta get through it were you like big
with rapping before you got locked up I
was rapping and I had like a studio but
like I never released music ever on like
YouTube or nothing I was literally just
it was just a place for us to [ __ ]
around and Gamble and meet people yeah
and serve people you think you sharpened
your your obviously your skills a lot
while being in jail with that pen right
in jail yeah not real rap
in jail definitely you know I wrote a
lot
and then I go you know I was like
reluctant a little bit at first to rap
because it's it's nasty in there you
don't really want to draw attention on
yourself I'm saying yeah especially I
mean I'm sure being a white dude that
raps is like and then like I know and
then like and then like you know I was
somebody on the street
like you weren't like a [ __ ] yeah
people knew who you were I was [ __ ]
fronting everybody like they knew
everybody was I was [ __ ] paying gas
bills like am I in the neighborhoods I
was in so like when I went to jail most
a lot of dudes were [ __ ] up on drugs I
was healthy you know I'm saying at that
time I was ready to rock fat boy so like
I feel you know a lot of times I feel
like you know like when I first went
there a lot of them dudes kind of got
behind me like the same way when I told
you them boys came to my cell and they
were like yo
I felt myself kind of turned into that a
little bit like trying to help out some
good people oh yeah it turned into you I
mean the big homie kinda
of sorts yeah but in a much more humble
way no for sure for sure for sure that's
if you move humble anywhere you go get
that you're gonna get that same energy
any race of people any religion anything
if you move humble and respectful the
[ __ ] you know what I mean it can still
go left no for sure it's crazy because
like uh
I feel like you came on the show two or
three years ago it was right before was
it was it 2019 or 2018
it was it was up at the station
with you and head yeah I want to say it
might have been 2019 or like early yeah
yeah yeah but I think you had been dming
me for a while
and um it was hungry I was trying to get
yeah you were hitting me a grip and I
forget if it was oh [ __ ]
I don't remember who like
you got water
we don't got water
now you want to grab something from the
from the Stow ski Broski my fault man
you were saying a few I could say it
might have been Steve Lobel Lobel well
yeah so
so
all right so one night I'm saying I get
a phone call that like something
happened to one of my friends
and they were gone they weren't coming
back for a while and uh so I was you
know it was a [ __ ] up day real
paranoid [ __ ] up day for me right
I wasn't involved in none of it but it
just was very close to me and you know
so I was home I remember I was laying
downstairs in the living room and my and
my phone rang and I'm like
hello he's like yo what's up bro just
want to let you know man [ __ ]
is proud of you
and I was like all right good looking
I'm like who is this he's like a shoe
man I was like oh I was like all right
where you at I don't know I don't even
know who this is but I was locked up
with so many different people that
someone's coming he got my number right
I'm not talking crazy with them all
right we can talk yeah who is this I'm
saying like where do I know you from
nah man you um
you weren't locked up with me I'm way
out west I'm like no I was out west pa2
he's like no no I'm out west I'm in
California locked up
so I just want to let you know we've
been looking at your progress
[ __ ] is proud of you with [ __ ]
so I was like all right
I appreciate it I said shoot where do I
know you from he said my name is Shu my
name is shook I said
shook I said is this sure what's your
last what's your last name he said
there's only one should [ __ ]
Suge Knight
so I was like
I'm saying I was like all right he's
like look I'm gonna have Scott
and Steve call you you know get with you
I was like all right well if this is
really you I apologize
just a random I don't know how Suge
Knight got my number right you know what
I'm saying
so the next day
Scott Storch faced on me it was like yo
we're gonna we're gonna get it in we
just we just got put on to you by you
know
Suge Knight I was like damn I was like
all right and I never even got to talk
to dude again because you can't call
back that's crazy I'm saying and then
you know it went dry for a while like
the whole summer went by and then my
homie hit me and was like yo
I just because I put a screenshot up
once when I started FaceTiming
yeah of course
put it up so that that got you know the
battery in one of my homies backs to
just keep the same way I'm I was at you
I got some thorough people around me
that are constantly just like I'll
breathing just like oh this bet [ __ ] you
know
so like he's like yeah I'm going out
there [ __ ] with him you're coming I'm
like all right come on we go out there
get with Steve get with Scott we got a
record in the tuck you know I got a Beat
by storage you know in the talk great
guy yeah man so you know it should be
happening crazy should be happening I
mean so you still haven't talked to Suge
Knight huh nah that's so crazy that like
whatever you were doing like got into
the on his radar while he's incarcerated
yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] wild man no
you know it's um
where that uh came from
with some cats from Jersey was that
shade four five one day and you know I
guess they were in close touch with
dude over here and you know they put
them I mean I found that out later
but um yeah man
I don't know if he's ever supposed to
get out but I'm sure if he does he'll
meet him one day or visit him I don't
know oh yeah no man like I said man I
wish everybody the best like I know
everybody you know um that's not a
um I know that that dude's been through
a lot of situations with a lot of people
out of course of course of course I mean
yeah yeah but you know but that's like
that's their business I'm saying 100
um being that you've lived the life
you've lived
when you listen to certain rappers
can you tell if they're full of [ __ ] or
not
sometimes
because I feel like the stuff you say in
your bars like people who know like like
you know Pusha D has a song If you know
you know like I feel like if you listen
to your [ __ ] you're saying some really
really like yeah some [ __ ] that I went
through damn like this dude is [ __ ]
serious like this is not some you know
fugazi dude yeah I can I can tell
I can tell sometimes sometimes though
you know some cats
are out here doing you know crazy
numbers with whatever they're doing on
the street and you know they make music
that's like future you know what I'm
saying no so like I think too sometimes
it's like they were close to it if
you've got a hard bar rapper though
right I can tell I can really I could
tell if it's only if it was him or his
homies I mean yeah okay okay that was
you and your big brother man it's not
rapping about your brother man aren't
you kind of like like glad that you got
all that [ __ ] out of the way when you
did before this fan no [ __ ] was popping
because God damn it's crazy right now
right absolutely it's like it's terrible
absolutely man you know like I said man
I I got tired of drugs in the Ecstasy
era man I was off I was over I was over
really doing drugs
when I was a kid so I was when I became
an adult like I've been on my own you
know I'm saying like I never had like a
good looking bro I never had like a net
under me that was gonna catch me right
so I had to accept like how miserable
life can be when you're a man by
yourself and you're [ __ ] broke you
know once you're 19 20 years old you're
a grown man I'm saying so you're you I
mean look you were pretty much out on
your own right away 17 on yeah and I
didn't have to be like my mother was
good family you know I'm saying good
parents and [ __ ]
um like separated but still like I mean
she showed that guy the dog
she [ __ ] went to my court dates for
me you know what I'm saying oh yeah
flew to flew to Pittsburgh from
Massachusetts had to fly into Pittsburgh
Rent A Car get a hotel just to visit me
that's amazing shout out to your mom man
shout out to Mom Dukes man my dad
visited me too man
um he'll come on check me out like once
a year because it's such a long drive
I'm like man I'd be like man don't even
[ __ ] come up with this [ __ ] nut
ass hillbilly [ __ ] please you're gonna
get a [ __ ] DUI oh yeah man get the
[ __ ] out shout out to the hillbillies
man hey what up y'all it's bootleg Kev
here to stop the interview sorry uh but
we gotta pay the [ __ ] bills and you
know not only do we have to pay the
bills but we also gotta take care of
them [ __ ] out there that's right make
sure you go to bluetooth.com right now
you know the bootleg kept podcast we are
presented by bluetooth proudly I happen
to every once in a while dabbling a
little chooski you know what I'm saying
and let me tell you something my dick
thanks me for it every single time uh so
listen if you go to Bluetooth use the
promo code bootleg you're gonna get your
first month supply for free now we're
talking the same active ingredient as as
Viagra as Cialis without the awkward
doctor's appointment visit you just go
online they get you taken care of it
gets delivered right to your [ __ ]
door and discreet packaging it's a
beautiful thing and how about this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and stackson
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavored chewables so what are we doing
go get you a little mint boy go get you
a little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
be a better jerk I'll tell you that all
right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground rap
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue tree you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole some all night
long bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg right now and they will give you
the first month for free so go do that
[ __ ] hey being a white rapper you I feel
like you automatically just inherit
random like uh redneck fans even though
you don't make that kind of [ __ ] you
might yeah have you noticed that
I I just noticed like this gradual of
every type of everyone everybody who I
know that's like super into like
ill rap [ __ ] like when I repost you on a
freestyle or whatever it is they're
always like yo he's crazy like I'm a fan
I [ __ ] with him like but you had
mentioned in uh the freestyle I think
you did for uh was on the radar there is
a weird uh obnoxious underbelly of White
rap
that is easy to get pulled into
because it's like uh it's just a
low-hanging fruit to me I'm talking
about uh
what's the [ __ ] guy who I beefed out
with in my YouTube comments that corny
bastard what's that Adam Calhoun oh okay
so like that kind of [ __ ] the Adam
Calhoun [ __ ] the burden [ __ ] the uh
there's just a lot of weird super like
cringy white rap [ __ ] going I was like I
guess the way to put it in the terms
would be like
if you like music
so like that doesn't people come up to
me and be like yo I listen to your [ __ ]
and that [ __ ] gives me the [ __ ]
chills like that should make like you
said or something like that and that's
because like I'm I'm saying I'm putting
my real life emotion into something so
that's why I'm doing it I'm doing it
because I'm making something that I feel
it's all it's all organic and it's all
real yeah
um it doesn't you know it's like [ __ ] to
live to when someone is just writing a
poem of the best [ __ ] that they can
think of and none of and there's no you
can tell that there's no passion or
nothing in it I mean they're really just
trying to ride a beat and they're just
they're doing it just to be doing it
because there is no passion in it there
is no message in it so what the [ __ ] are
you doing sir people like who pay
attention to lyrics and appreciate [ __ ]
like that that was going to get tired or
something here that's like doing them
country singers be like well that's what
I give I think you mentioned the Calhoun
dude and the Upchurch guy right oh yeah
yeah but not in like a negative one but
this ain't not in a negative way but
this ain't that [ __ ] we front work if
they burn us then it's guns first
yeah you're a rat I heard the Upchurch
guy's a nice guy but I don't know they
probably I wish them both the best uh
yeah uh you had talked to well you and
Millie supposed to be doing some [ __ ]
together a whole project that's my dog
man great guy yeah yeah [ __ ] right
you know what's crazy I met Millie's in
2012 at South by Southwest at the Hyatt
[ __ ] Lobby that guy's been at it for
years man well you know what I'm saying
that he's you know the [ __ ] he's got
going on right now he's killing it yeah
he deserves it 100 and he's official too
he's official official yeah absolutely
like you know you asked me a certain
people yeah that guy's official
absolutely
um you've had some pretty big moments in
terms of just like people acknowledging
the movement acknowledging you as you
know just I mean obviously Meeks posted
your [ __ ] uh shout out Meek man Snoop
Dogg of recent like what's what's been
like one of the more crazier things that
like kind of made you like pinch
yourself like damn I was [ __ ] in
prison you know seven years ago like now
so and so is all my [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
is wild
yeah that happens a lot and but what I
do is I just
I'd be like shut the [ __ ] up don't even
think about it stay humble what's the
next joint yeah because if you gave her
two wrapped up into them what am I doing
for rollout for this next project I know
we're not going where did it not go what
didn't I do I'm saying and I've had
two children born you know and you know
what I'm saying in the last three years
I've had two children born so wow well
congrats yeah not the same baby mom two
bedrooms yeah yeah I got three kids yeah
so you know I just had two in the last
you know I'm saying because you got two
young ones right now that's that's why
yeah yeah and my oldest son he's playing
you know football soccer it's ten oh
nice little little dude now man football
and soccer man once they hit like eight
they become like little dudes low-key I
think anything before that you really
look good but like damn like I gotta
watch what I say in front of you now
because you really be knowing about [ __ ]
yeah it's definitely right now at this
time in my life my music is starting to
connect to my home life because my I
have a child old enough to understand
stuff so and that's important too
there's some explaining to do yeah no my
I have an eight-year-old who is going on
30. a lot of these dudes ain't there for
their kids a lot of these dudes like
they're lit but they're kids they're
[ __ ] 37 year old kids right they got
kids out there they don't take care of
their kids there's no way they're taking
care of their kids because I be with my
kids so I know there's no [ __ ] way
that a lot of these cats really have
that and I wouldn't really sacrifice
that relationship with my kids if I got
anything if I got to get rich slower
then I will you know I'm saying I'm
still gonna grind I'll just sleep less
that's my that's my trick that's amazing
you know I see you do it too I'm trying
to work life balances and salute to
everybody who don't I mean don't get it
twisted that's there are a lot of 37
year old children running around here
but you know and I'm not in terms of
just how they live right but I'm not
saying oh just because they don't have
kids that they're [ __ ] children I
don't mean like that no so they did is
that they don't take care of their kids
right there's people out to take care of
your [ __ ] kids that's what I'm saying
yeah you know
you know my baby mom makes it easy too
though you know what I'm saying it's
important man it's important to have the
right person to like understand your
mission especially being an artist like
they just somebody just call home today
a relative
and said that like
you know he just landed in a new in a
County Jail up
and the guards got my [ __ ] on YouTube
with the with the speaker with my shit's
playing on YouTube and the cell block
right now what the [ __ ] the dudes are
going up to the cell like yo that that's
your family that's your people throwing
food you know it's like that right now
because I really came in heavy like you
know I'm saying I put a lot of people on
a lot of people put a lot of people on a
lot a lot of people wow Massachusetts
Jersey New Hampshire Delaware
Pennsylvania all the way you know back
then
so my relationships some of those people
that you know I had these relationships
with you know we're all out of the
streets now but some of these people
know me and you know each other now you
know what I mean yeah we know we
wouldn't [ __ ] each other over you know I
have that relationship with like all
these these people
you know I'm saying you know so and it's
not all from drugs you know I'm saying
it's right it's from just being well
being solid back in the day it really
was but you know those relationships
turned into other things people ended up
places a lot of people dead a lot of
people in jail some people work at
[ __ ] in the scope yeah you know what
I'm saying that's crazy man you know
that's my path and I'm still not where I
want to go but my character is on a beam
explain to me like uh what was the
moment like when you first get out where
you decided to go like ten toes in on
this rap [ __ ] because I'm assuming like
I was on a roof getting paid 80 a day
about to fall off that [ __ ] everything
like doing manual labor not knowing what
I was doing nothing unskilled doing my
construction I'm coming and I'm coming
out of jail and everyone's like you
better go out there and [ __ ] that [ __ ]
up like because I'm I'm you know I hit
home and the people like I said I've
said this before like people weren't as
quick to want to help you because
they're like what are you doing you're
trying to rap dude like yeah come on man
get a [ __ ] job you just got out
jail man yeah people who care about you
yep they'll be the most honest with you
yeah
and you gotta decide I like right there
like all right what am I doing it's
balls to the wall
Balls to the walls gotta believe just go
believe in yourself and then you know
when you start knocking down doors you'd
be like oh yeah I'm a [ __ ] door
knocker Downer you know what I'm saying
you're more than one way knocking on
those doors man uh bro have you ever
thought about acting
I feel like you could be like typecasted
in the town you just got me my new would
you get me Breeze what's it called the
check what's it from
got my first you got a sad yeah yeah I
got my sag check from that BT yeah man
it'll be in the town part too man I feel
like you could just be typecasted in
every Ben Affleck gangster movie forever
shout out slain man slain you get to hey
shout out my guy slain slain's a dope
rappers you know he's somebody who I
look up to a lot with what he did great
guy man great guy one I had a legendary
uh night in Las Vegas with slain and a
bunch of porn stars in 2012 my God
static selector was there
yeah
I may or may not have gotten fellatio in
front of them in the back of a limo
yeah whatever it was a long time ago
before I knew my wife shout out status
shout out to those uh what was what's
the name of the porn Awards [ __ ]
um the big ones avians ABN Awards in
Vegas those weekends were crazy
yeah I missed those yeah you missed the
man but how do you like like when you're
in prison don't they like take that [ __ ]
from you like if somehow you manage to
get like a [ __ ] hustler in there
isn't that Contraband yeah yeah it's a
write-up yeah so you get in trouble for
that
I'm saying certain guards probably
realize that that ship is breeding
homosexuality and I think you know a lot
of times guards are the ones taking the
magazine in and taking to the copy
machine printing all them Black and
Whites and giving them to the block so
you know probably feeling bad for dudes
you know what I'm saying oh so like
you're like yeah yo like most of the
[ __ ] that comes into jail is coming from
a guard who's trying to be thorough I
ain't gonna say a thorough guard because
there's no such thing but somebody
someone a guard who works or
administrator who works inside the jail
is trying to be thorough you know what
I'm saying that yeah because I feel like
a lot of people like CEOs I feel like
there's two types of CEOs somebody who's
just like look this is a job it is what
it is good benefits and then there's the
[ __ ] who grew up not getting no
[ __ ] who are probably [ __ ] in high
school and that this is their way oh man
it's bad bro you know what the guys I'm
talking about they don't like me and
they're just the worst but I'm you know
I'm a real sociopath [ __ ] I mean I can
manipulate those people too if I need to
what I'm saying but yeah those people
are the worst though
yo it's bootleg Kev here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture shout out my guy
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you two hundred dollars on top of
that to gamble with for free if you put
in a thousand dollars they're gonna
match that deposit with a free thousand
dollar shoe to gamble with right now so
what the [ __ ] are you waiting for let's
get this money let's watch some [ __ ]
football and let's get paid with my
bookie definitely it gets nasty be a
nice hustle if you were it's hard when
those people band up those people by
themselves are one thing but when you
find a certain like a crew of [ __ ]
oh man it's just the whole Cruise a
bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] then the other
Crews selling black and white nudie
magazines that's how I'll be at them
Western PA prisons and them prisons are
in towns and they're owned by the the
people in the town you know what I'm
saying I just started watching have you
watched the mayor of Kingstown no I see
it's with uh Jeremy Renner the guy from
Hurt Locker it's about like that it's
about like this this little town
it might be in like that area actually
I'm pretty sure it is and it's like
about like how this prison kind of feeds
the whole town like jobs it does man the
way my fault the way they uh the way
they mark up commissary like with nobody
overseeing them you understand that it's
like a straight flip I mean there's no
nobody's involved like they're just
buying [ __ ] that's approved and they're
marking it up as they see fit and
selling it at commissary that's selling
it to the that's crazy they're locking
you in a place you might get like a
bottle of these yeah so they're locking
you in a place right for whatever
whatever controlling the market on
everything you can buy yeah really I
mean really and and then like
um the way that they're streaming the
music in there and [ __ ] like I'm glad
I'm on I'm on all them tablets and [ __ ]
but like you can get a tablet in there
everybody got a tab my music's on all
the tablets we fight to make sure my
shit's on the tablets what is the is it
like Spotify like what is it nah it's
like a [ __ ] they get like a tablet
and they have like a site that I forget
it it's not JPay it's something else or
it might be I remember JPay I was out of
jail I just I left and got out of prison
right before the tablets came and the
tobacco got taken out they took all the
tobacco out so tablets there's like a
specific
platform that like you go you get a
tablet and like you can call people from
it from your cell so you don't have to
worry about like the phone line no more
yeah I got a homie who texts me
regularly from prison from federal
prison and uh he's in Ohio he's like I
talked to him all like every week like
he's just texting me about [ __ ] hey did
you see what happened I'm like yeah I
don't know like I feel like my time
would have been a lot harder if I'd had
a phone
but I you know I would have I would I
wanted one when I was in there of course
that at all times but to have a phone
full time while you're doing all them
years is like it's almost like it's
teasing you like what you're missing
yeah as opposed to focusing on what's in
front of you oh [ __ ] that's real I can
imagine people go through like college
like damn oh [ __ ] hurts crazy man that
[ __ ] hurts so I'm glad I just lock them
just leave me alone I'm gonna be in I'll
just
hunker down and live life right here
until it's time to go you know so your
new album uh explain the title no matter
what
yeah what was what I mean this is no
matter Relentless yeah I mean we see no
matter what like yeah that's yeah we
just talked about everything you [ __ ]
went through yeah you know and like you
know
other people have had rougher paper
routes than me I'm not complaining but
yeah that's that's the best you ask why
wear a mask what it is you got Chris
Webby on the album shout out to Chris
Webby good friend great guy yeah man
he's got a pretty sick fan base too you
say you were on the road a little bit
with him yeah he took me to do some
shows with him and [ __ ]
and um the kid Ritz was out there with
him and rich is old as [ __ ] be clear he
is not a kid I [ __ ] with red so great
guy I [ __ ] with him too maybe a little
too much did the Judgment of my own
[ __ ] you know existence but yeah man
right he could rap his ass off yeah and
he is probably the
one day Ritz's movie will come out and
it will be great
Ritz is a wild boy that's all I could
say yeah he's definitely uh I only
kicked it with him for a little bit but
we're definitely gonna link again yeah
you guys should do a record together
yeah because he can like he does The
Chopping where he'd be rapping fast but
people don't know he could do he
actually has like a whole boom bap tape
that he never put out just to show
people that he doesn't have to rap that
way
but racist fire who else on the album
you said uh Webby who else oh um Sue
surf Sue surf yeah man shout out he's
one of them ones man yeah man he's
somebody that I always wanted to work
with so when the opportunity came up I
was glad we were able to you know I'm
saying it with a link
shoot that video get all that out and
then I got another one with Hardo
from from Pittsburgh Pittsburgh he's so
fire yo real rap man you gotta get
something I know me you know what I've
had him on my show I feel like we've
I've been tapping with harder for a long
time I feel like 2017 he came on my show
okay but I just ran into him at South by
and uh I [ __ ] with Hardo man yeah he'd
be talking [ __ ] he's another one people
that when they talk that [ __ ] yeah he's
fine what I'm saying yeah shout out to
Pittsburgh man wear it up I saw uh did
you have a relationship with the battle
rapper who just passed away Pat yeah
real good relationship yeah I saw he you
know I saw you just post about him um
I don't know the circumstances in which
he died man but like uh he was by all
accounts one of the I'm not like super I
think I think he was he's to me you know
what I'm saying and I said this before
you know I'm saying he passed but uh he
was number one him in disaster to me
were the best two battle rappers I ever
heard you know right then some other
cats though in a different way like I'm
a big fan of Ness
that's a different Lane but all in from
nitty yeah yeah I gotta get more caught
up but uh but back to Pat though Pat's a
legend
forever I'm saying how'd you guys end up
uh like becoming friends [ __ ] I think it
was showing love through internet you
know what I'm saying but Pat was one of
them people that like
you know voice text you right I'm saying
back and forth all day we talk every day
did your voice text back or did you talk
all day not whatever however you know
what I'm saying however but me and Pat
was tight bro that sucks man yeah it
feels because it's crazy because I
remember seeing that he had passed away
and then I watched his that's like
really eerie like when someone dies and
like their story is still up from the
day of and it's like [ __ ] man like this
dude was just breathing like eight hours
ago like it's you just never know when
your time can come man he was the last
person I could think of that you know
what I'm saying crap right right right
right it's unfortunate man rest in peace
very very emotional about that
um for you where do you where do you go
from here because when you get to look
like the BT Cipher major labels will
start knocking if they haven't already
been knocking I know you've been close
to some situations with you know some
some other rap
I wouldn't say Cruise labels whatever
but uh are you looking to sign are you
like where are you at in terms of like
the rap [ __ ] like movie I'm in a good
place right because like I can draw
music when I want
um I got a good situation with distro I
mean shot all my people over at next
yeah I got a good situation it could
always be better
but you know I learned that every time I
drop I'm becoming you know every time I
perform every time I do anything I'm
just increasing what I got going on
you're increasing your reach every time
yeah so like you know I I expect more
you know what I'm saying so I just keep
you know I'm I'm all ears you know what
I'm saying but right now I'm
self-sufficient so I'm not I'm not
drowning no more like I was I was
drowning yeah cause like I think the
goal always should be when you're out
you're broke I'm broke
right parole right with kids [ __ ] broke
on parole with kids
I'm saying trying to make it
crying it out
I think anyone's like if anybody can
successfully get to the point where they
can get their bills paid off of this rap
[ __ ] like you made it like to be honest
like you made it but every time you
get to the top of a hill you gotta keep
going man see what you see another
Mountain you didn't see it till you got
to the top it's crazy that's real cause
like being around Webby like like
learning yeah he does things and seeing
how they do you know like what the you
know well I mean I feel like you
probably would do that a few different
times
financially you probably had a lot of
money you know growing up before you
went to prison but like I feel like you
always think damn if I ever made this
amount of money I'll be [ __ ] set and
then you get to that amount of money and
then you don't even think about and
you're just like I need more like we got
to keep this [ __ ] going yeah it's it's
never It's never enough and the world
you know and having a phone in front of
you to show you the things you don't
have and the things you're not doing
right that that will drive you and
poison you you know what I'm saying but
it'll drive you it drives me it's a
beautiful thing man beautiful thing man
no matter what we gotta stop the
interview tell you about our partners at
Odd Socks well first of all let's check
out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
going to figure out a way to give them
away though uh but look Odd Socks the
most comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
altogether bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
how uh like uh often like you you live
with your kids full time right yeah so
when you're like not with them when
you're on the road when you're doing the
Chris Webby [ __ ] is it like
is it like tough to be away from the
kids for like a long amount of time I
mean like yeah but you know like there's
face time there's Face Time Changes the
game a little bit but you know as men
you know just we gotta go provide you
gotta go hunt then the food you know
what I mean that's what I tell my wife
you know and you know the women can hunt
too that I mean she's she's taking care
of the kids I'm out getting this money
you gotta find that child care you gotta
pay for that you gotta run for that too
yeah go hunt that down I'm saying yeah
get a little vacation from the kids you
get that date night popping no it's hard
it's been it's been a tough busy couple
years I'm saying and I'm grateful
so you know I look forward to
being able to do more is there uh I've
been restricted I've been everything
when did you get off parole
[ __ ] when did I get off when did I get
it
it was was it 2019 no I was 20. so you
got off yo I got it it was right before
cover jumped but right before right
before covet it was [ __ ] January
right before cover jumped a couple
months later
so you were just like that was like your
first time being shut up shut up Prince
Holloway free from the system in almost
20 years right and Jack McMahon yeah
yeah that was it I walked out of there
was like [ __ ] you never coming back I
was like damn I go do something get
right out now
terrible terrible mentality oh you know
I didn't do that but that's you know oh
man shout out to you man
um is there gonna be any other
I mean like you said you did [ __ ] with
Green Lantern like is there any other uh
ideas or thoughts of doing like another
full collab project with another
producer
yeah
[ __ ] right
yeah absolutely there's other producers
they're like you you and Derringer would
be crazy yeah man real quick too
like I said man this should be flowing
out of me like right now I'm making the
best music you could put me on like a
trap beat some kids put me on like a
trap beat the other night oh what's the
mass shout out to Worcester yeah we're
all right and uh
you know I got right on that [ __ ] and
swagged it out I don't mind putting
Harmony on something I do I feel like
lyric I feel like I'm acing everybody on
that too okay awesome you know not
trying I mean real rap though I'm Ace
and [ __ ] like the best music flowing out
of me
the best [ __ ] you know I'm writing the
best [ __ ] who's your favorite uh like
outside of you or your immediate crew
like uh like what are you just a fan of
right now in hip hop
right now like who do I listen to like
what's your favorite album this year how
about that
that I that wasn't mine or that you
weren't a part of of course because I'm
gonna be in love with mine
well I'm on it but I'm a bit you know
Millie's album is dope yeah I'm on it
though but that one number one yeah you
know on iTunes and all that [ __ ]
um other [ __ ] that came out this year
2022 man
this year
I like what uh Harry frog got going with
Jay worthy yeah that album is crazy
actually Jay Worthy's been on a crazy
run I met Jay worthy back out here like
with weeder you know I was out here with
G weeder yeah he's on he's on a he's on
a [ __ ] crazy run just he's just I
feel like he's dropping a new album
every Tuesday Pusher T album is crazy
this year
uh I like yo on some real [ __ ] I'll be
bumping names and [ __ ] names is [ __ ]
fire I love nems man he's somebody else
that we had on like crazy early and like
I'm just so glad he caught his wave and
like people are starting to pay
attention to like just he's such a his
[ __ ] been disrespectful
I feel like he got less disrespectful
lately
and then uh there's this kid in Philly
uh Leaf Ward
I mean this you know who I've been
listening to a lot
dope all right man well listen uh go get
the album no matter what yeah no matter
what right that's the hardest [ __ ] out
this year man go run that [ __ ] up I'm
sure there's gonna be a whole lot more
music coming soon
yeah some more tour dates maybe yeah
definitely definitely we definitely
Millie's on the way maybe yeah also man
don't forget to go get me on that uh you
know black soprano family album Long
Live DJ Shay that's on yep yeah was
everybody talking you guys uh doing a
little uh situation over there at the
BSF oh yeah there's lots of yeah there's
lots of uh
lots of things going on I mean lots of
Talk would you rather like build your
own [ __ ] though like low-key I'm already
building my own [ __ ] that's what I mean
like it probably is easy to like me and
my man SK I mean that's what if you look
on a lot of my albums I got my man sknj
with me what's the name of your [ __ ]
just shout it out just so people know
like you know I mean right my LLC is OT
the real but I also have soup kitchen
music group too okay soup kitchen but
yeah yeah but
OT the real is signed to OT the real
it's just one one I see what you did
there sole proprietorship I love it I'm
hitting to the LLC game I got a few my
man SK put me on to do that [ __ ] that's
why he's with that [ __ ] once you start
making more money you're gonna have to
get that S Corp and then you're gonna
put your lady on as an employee and your
kids on that trust yeah you get better
better tax breaks you know
shout out to the S Corp hustle hey well
listen man appreciate you pulling up bro
and today look we're gonna do freestyles
you can watch that YouTube video as well
we're gonna put it somewhere over here
let's go go get that no matter what
right now let's go OT the real fire